اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء حكومه جديده
واسعه التمثيل جاءت وليده مخرجات الحوار
الوطني الذي جمع كثيرا من مكونات المشهد
السياسي في السودان هكذا قدمت السلطات
السودانيه التشكيله الوزاريه الجديده التي
وصفت بالوفاق في اشاره الى عدد من الاحزاب
يتقدمها المؤتمر الشعبي الذي اسسه الراحل
حسن الترابي التحقت بالحكم ضمن الصيغه
الحكوميه الجديده خطوه اثارت السؤال عما
ستفرض من متغيرات على المشهد السوداني
المترع بكثير من التحديات والتعقيدات
تقرير المسلم الكباشي ثم نبدا
النقاش حكومه سودانيه جديده ولدت بعد
انتظار طويل ومخاض عسير يراسها هذه المره
الفريق اول بكري حسن صالح بوصفه الجديد
رئيسا للوزراء وهي صفه جاءت بها مقررات
مؤتمر الحوار الوطني الذي امتدت مداولاته
لاكثر من عامين انتقلت بعده البلاد من
نظام رئاسي محض الى اخر هاجين يشارك فيه
رئيس الوزراء رئيس الدوله بعض سلطاته
حكومه فضل رئيس وزرائها ان يسميها حكومه
كفاءات على الرغم من انها جاءت محاصصه بين
اكثر من 100 حزب وحركه الامر الذي جاء بها
على غير ما يشتهي الراي العام السوداني
وتتحمله الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الصعبه
والمنهك بالوضع السياسي اذ ان مجلسا
للوزراء به اكثر من 30 وزيرا مركزيا ومن
45 وزير دوله له ابعد من ان يتوافق مع
احلام الناس في فاعليه حكوميه تحل
المشكلات المعيشيه والتنمويه احتفظ حزب
المؤتمر الوطني الحاكم باعمده السلطه في
الحكومه الجديده فقد كانت مناصب السياده
الثلاثه وهي الخارجيه والماليه والداخليه
من نصيبه ومن هنا يلح سؤال ان كانت ذات
السياسات القديمه هي التي ستدير البلاد ام
في الافق شيء جديد جدول اعمال مزدحم
باولوية
التي ما عادت محتمله لغالب الناس في وطن
يزخر بموارد طبيعيه وثراء يهزمه سوء
الاداره تعتبر مقررات الحوار الوطني ان من
اهم واجبات الحكومه الجديده تهيئه البلاد
الى وضع انتقالي ينتهي في العام 2020 حيث
يجب ان تستكمل شروط انتخابات حره ونزيهه
من سعه في الحريات العامه والصحفيه
والتزام صارم بحقوق الانسان وتعديل جميع
القوانين الكابحه للحريات لتطوى بذلك صفحه
الحزب المسيطر في مواجهه معارضات سلميه
ومسلحه تختلف معه في اصول النظام السياسي
ويتم ذلك في سياق استكمال تطبيع العلاقات
مع امريكا واوروبا بما يخرج البلاد من
دائره ازمه نظام الحكم الى افق ارحب
للتنافس السياسي تاتي هذه الحكومه الاولى
بعد انتهاء جلسات مؤتمر الحوار الوطني
الطويله بينما لا ترى قوا سياسيه سلميه
واخرى مسلحه في كل ما حدث غير مزيد من
الهروب الى الامام وتجنب لطريق الاصلاح
الحقيقي المؤدي الى استدامه الاستقرار في
السودان لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
الخرطوم مريم الصادق المهدي نائبه رئيس
حزب الامه القوميه كما ينضم الينا من هناك
ايضا عبر الهاتف الامين عبد الرازق الامين
السياسي لحزب المؤتمر الشعبي ابدا معك
سيده مريم هل تشكيله هذه الحكومه هي اقصى
ما كانت تامله المعارضه بعد الحوار
السياسي مع
السلطه مرحبا بك استاذ حسن ومرحبا بكل
مشاهدك والمشاهدات ولا شك ان الاجابه هي
لا فكما جاء في تقريركم الضافي ان هذه
الحكومه التي
سميت مغالطه
بالوفاق بها اكثر من 100 حزب سياسي وبها
اكثر من 30 مشتقات اسم
لمسميات حركات مسلحه وفي ذات الوقت كما
تفضلتم بعد بعد بالتالي يعوز في المقام
الاول اي نوع من التجانس فيما بينها وكما
ذكر
المشير عمر حسن البشير نفسه انها كيكه
وكيكه صغيره على الايدي الكثيره الطامحه
الامر الثاني والمهم جدا انه يعوز تماما
البرنامج لانه كما تعلم المفترض ان تنفذ
مخرجات ما اسمي بالحوار وفي ذات الوقت هذه
المخرجات افرغت
بشهاده المشاركين فيها خاصه في مساله
الحريات بصوره اساسيه وكانت دي لغايه اخر
لحظه
شهاده مم المت الشب نعم سيده مريم المعروف
يعني انه ليست كل المطالب التي يمكن ان
يتقدم بها اي حزب او اي معارضه اي ستلب
دائما هناك الحد الادنى وهناك وسط الطريق
وربما هذا ما حصل مع البرلمان عندما اقر
عندما اقر بعض القوانين المتعلقه بالحريات
لكنك ذكرتي بانه فيها اكثر من حزب اكثر من
100 حزب سياسي هل هذا ينقص من قيمتها ام
يضيف اليها ويؤكد انها
وفاقي بالتاكيد ينقص من قيمتها
لانه هو اساسا افتعال ان هناك تشرم واسع
في الحركه السياسيه الحركه السياسيه الان
في السودان نسبه لشده الازمه في الحقيقه
برامجها تكاد تكون متطابقه بالتالي ليس
العبره بكم الاحزاب انما
بالبرامج الذي يحقق كما تفضلت الحد الادنى
اللي هو السلام السلام لا يوجد سلام في
السودان تماما صحيح الحكومه عبر انشاء
مليشيات غير دستوريه عملت قمعه العديد من
الحركات الم
ولكن نشا نوع جديد من النزاع الخطير في
الاخر المؤدى واحد ان هناك لا يوجد امن
ولا يوجد استقرار وبالتالي لا يوجد افق
للتنميه كذلك مساله التوافق ادنى على
الحوكمه بحيث تكون عفوا ساعود اليك سيده
مريم لكن دعيني انتقل هنا الى الى السيد
كمال
عمر او عفوا الى الامين عبد الرازق الامين
السياسي لحزب المؤتمر الشعبي لاساله عن
رايه فيما قلت وعن رايه في هذه التشكيله
الحكوميه الجديده سيد
الامين سيد الامين انت
معي سيد الامين عبد
الرازق يبدو ان السيد الامين عبد الرازق
لا يسمعني عبر الهاتف ساعود الى من جديد
اذا تمكنت لكن اعود اليك سيده مريم كنت
تتحدثين عن الحوكمه وموضوع
الحوكمه في فيما يتعلق بموضوع الحكومه
تفضلي نعم صحيح المطلوب الادنى هو ان توفر
السلام السلام
منعدم تماما وهناك خطر جديد من انه كثير
من الحركات المسلحه والمليشيات مسلحه تدلف
الى مساله ان يكون هناك عمل بالوكاله عن
اخرين وبالتالي الامر الان الحروب القبليه
ما بين الاهل الذين لم يسبق لهم مثل هذه
المواجهات ب مختلف بطون القبائل في خاصه
في غرب السودان دارفور وكردفان
وغيرها متفشيه بصوره خطيره الامر الثاني
هو التصالح الادنى على الحوكمه عبر ان
يكون هناك شفافيه ان يكون هناك مشاركه كما
تعلم يا سيدي الان نحن نعاني اعلى درجات
الفساد والتعتيم بحيث انه كل اموال
البترول غير معروف اين ذهبت وحتى الان كل
البنى التحتيه التي تمت تمت بقروض ربويه
من الصين في الغالب ومن جهات اخرى ايضا
مساله الحريات مساله الحريات مساله مهمه
جدا كاساس لان يشعر المواطنين بانهم
مواطنين في في في
بلدهم لا زال سده سيده مريم ربما ربما
يمكن تسميه هذه النقاط التي تتحدثين بها
تحديات امام الحكومه الجديده التي عليها
ان تنفذ مخرجات الحوار الوطني ماذا يقول
في ذلك الامين عبد الرازق والذي هو الامين
السياسي لحزب المؤتمر الشعبي اريد ان اسمع
رايه اولا في في هذه الحكومه التي
تنتقدين توسعتها بهذا الشكل وع عدم
التفافها حول برنامج واحد او تناقض
البرامج في ما بين الاحزاب المؤتلفه فيها
سيد الامين
تفضل السلام عليك وعلى ضيفتك
الكريمه مريم الصابق المهدي ويبدو اننا
سنكون على موعد قريبا ان شاء الله
للتواصل اول حاجه حكومه الوفاق
الوطني هي
حكومه متفقه على برنامجها اصلا يعني ام هي
برنامجها مخرجات الحوار نعم ولكن بعد ذلك
هي تحتاج الى
تفصيل وقتي لهذا البرنامج لكن برنامج هو
تنفيذ مخرجات الحوار وهي حكومه يجب ان
تبدا
باولوية تسع الجميع ليس
تسع مكونات حكومه الوفاق الوطني فقط ولكن
تسع الشعب السوداني نحن نحتاج الى حريات
تسعى الشعب السوداني وما تحصلنا عليه من
خلال مخرجات الحوار نعتقد انه يمكن ان
يتطور الى حريات شامله ترضي كل الشعب
السوداني وترضي حتى الاخوان في المعارضه
الاخت مريم الصدوي وغيرها وحكومه يجب ان
ان تلتفت الى معاش الناس الى الاغتصاب الى
اصلاح الاغتصاب هذه واحده من من الاولويات
التي يمكن نعم سيد الامين يعني اول ما
ذكرت قلت بانكم ستكونون على موعد للتواصل
مع حزب الامه القومي لماذا انتم الان جزء
من الحكومه وهم خارج الحكومه ما سبب هذا
التواصل وماذا تهدف
اليه نحن كنا طبعا في هو الاجماع
الوطني مع بعض يعني ونحن لدينا مشتركات
كثيره جدا سنحاول ان نثبت معهم هذه
المشتركات ونتناقش
ونطور وصولنا الى اتفاق في المختلفات شعب
السوداني كله يتفق في انه يريد حريه الشعب
السوداني كله يتفق انه يريد ايقاف الحرب
الشعب السوداني كله يتحدث عن حل مشكله
الاقتصاد ومشكله الاقتصاد المعيشي
بالتحديد ومعاش الناس نحن في ميثاق
والاجماع الوطني سابقا كنا نتفق في كل هذه
القضايا وهذه القضايا مل اتفاق واذا ف
نطورها ما اتفقنا عليه ونتحاور فيما
اختلفنا عليه نحن ليس بعيدين من كل
الح القادمه ونحن شركاء في حكومه الم
الوطني ان شاء الله سنتواصل مع كل
القوه داخل السودان داخل السودان وكل
القوى خارج السودان لماذا لم تتواصلوا
معهم قبل ان تكونوا جزء من هذه الحكومه
نحن ان شاء الله كما قلت سنتواصل معكم في
الفترات القادمه بصوره
اوسع ما كان الباب مقفولا اصلا للتواصل
معه مع الامام السابق المهدي ومعروف اننا
يعني دناه الى مؤتمرنا العام ودعناه الى
الشيخ حسن الترابي فحضر هذا نوع من
التواصل ولكن اتكلم عن التواصل السياسي في
القضايا السياسيه والحوار نحن قلوبنا
مفتوحه وعقولنا مفتوحه وايدنا ممدوده لكل
هوو سياسيه في السودان داخل السودان وخارج
السودان الممانعه وغير الممانعه الحامل
للسلاح وغير الحامل للسلاح كلها عقولنا
مفتوحه لها وايدينا ممدوده لها للحوار من
اجل مخرج للمشكل
السوداني ومخرجات الحوار كما قال الاماره
السابق الماذا انها يمكن ان تلبي ان تلبي
وتحل كثير من مشاكل السودان ولذلك سنتواصل
معه ومع غيره من القوى الحزب الشوعي
و ليس لاننا في حكومه الوفاق الوطني لا
نتواصل مع الاخرين دعني اعود لسيده مريم
الصادق المهدي سيده مريم يعني من خلال ما
سمعت منك ومن السيد الامين الى اي مدى
يمكن ان نقول الان بانه هذه الحكومه هذه
التشكيله الجديده استطاعت ان تخرق صفوف
المعارضه وان تجعل المعارضه صفين صف معارض
موالي اذا صح التعبير وصف بقي على معارضته
السابقه قبل تشكيل
الحكومه لا ليست ليس هذا من فعل هذه
الحكومه هذا امر تم منذ حوالي ثلاثه اعوام
منذ ان بدا هذا الحوار لكن دعني اعود يا
سيدي لما تحدث عنه الاستاذ الامين لا يوجد
برامج ولا توجد استراتيجيه لهذه الحكومه
ولا يوجد لديها زمن حتى لانه المخرجات هي
مجرد توصيات حوالي 1000 توصيه او تزيد
منها ثلثي التوصيات خاصه بالوضع الاقتصادي
مترادفه ومتناقض احيانا وغيره بالتالي لا
المخرجات لا تشكل برامج ولا تشكل
استراتيجيه لا توجد استراتيجيه الامر
الثاني مفترض ان يكون هناك انتخابات بعد
عامين او ثلاث
اعوام ما في زمن لهذه الحكومه حتى لتتجانس
وتعمل كل المطلوب منها ولكن الامر المهم
والاهم لعله لكي لا ندخل في في غلاط انحنا
توجد فرصه حقيقيه لا يوجد في السودان من
يسموا انفسهم او من هم مانعين للحوار في
السودان الحقيقه هي اجماع كل القوى
السياسيه ولكن الكل يتحدث عن خطوات حقيقيه
لتجعل الحوار حوار منتج
وفعال وحوار ينهي حاله الاحتقان الشديد
والغضب الشديد والياس الشديد وسط الشعب
السوداني هذا الامر تم ووقعنا عليه عبر
خارطه الطريق التي يش تشرف عليها الاليه
الافريقيه الرفيعه وقعت عليها الحكومه
ممثله باطرافها وقعت عليها المعارضه ممثله
باطرافها والمفترض ان تمضي قدما كان يمكن
لهذه المخرجات وهذا الحوار الذي ابتدره
المشير عمر البشير بالداخل ان يكون خطوه
نحو احداث الحوار الحقيقي الذي نتطلع اليه
بل ندعو اليه جميعا
ولكن بدلا من ذلك دخلنا في مغالطات انه
هذا هو الحوار وانتهى ومن من من من يريد
ان يلحق فليلحق ومن لا يريد فنحن ماضون
وتمضي لا سفينه الانقاذ تمضي لا و تبطلها
الرياح هذه الشعارات التي ظلت تردد بصوره
جوفاء لمده 28 سنه اوردت السودان موارد
التهلكه كامله الان التطلع من قبل هذه
الحكومه انه يكون هناك رفع للعقوبات
الامريكيه وان يكون هناك ضخل للاموال
السعوديه او الاموال الخليجيه عموما
وبالتالي بهذه الصوره هي تخرج من الازمه
السياسيه صحيح انه الازمه في مقام الاول
وتبدي و تفجره والمعاناه اليوميه للشعب هي
ازمه اقتصاديه ولكن لا يمكن لاقتصاد ان
يزدهر في في ظل هذا الاحتقان السياسي
والاستقطاب السياسي الذي من الواضح لكل
منق السمع او لم يلقي السمع في السودان
انه انها الحكومه تعمل على تمديد الزمن
وتعمل على ان ان ان تمدد لزمن دون ان يحدث
اصلاح حقيقي ودون ان ي تحصل مواطنه حقيقيه
لذلك
هوح واضح ساعود الى سيد الرازق ساعود الى
سيد الرازق عبر
الهاتف يعني استمعت الى وجهه نظر السيده
مريم بالنهايه مخرجات الحوار الوطني ليست
اكثر من توصيات وليست برنامج محدد كما
يفترض بالحكومه ان يكون برنامجها وبالتالي
ليس هناك
زمن محدد ما رايك اول حاجه مخرجات الحوار
طبعا ناقشت كل كل قضايا الازمه السودانيه
والحكومه ستخرج من هذه المخرجات برامج
تفصيليه هي الحكومه يعني كونت بالامس يعني
كيف يقال لها انها ليس لديها برنامج
الحكومه ستكون لها استراتيجيه مستوحاه من
مخرجات الحوار ومعتمده عليها وستكون لها
برامج تفصيلي ونحن في حزب المؤتمر الشعبي
مع الاخرين ان شاء الله ومع السيد رئيس
الوزراء بكر حسن صالح سنعمل على ان يكون
هناك برنامج تفصيلي لكل وزاره ولكل لكل
المجلس مجتمعا وفي كل القضايا التي عالجها
الحوار الوطني اما بالنسبه انه الحوار لا
الحوار لا ينتهي الحوار السياسي لا ينتهي
اصلا
يعني ابدا الحوار انت صحيح صحيح اننا
وصلنا الى مخرجات
ولكن الحوار مفتوح بين القوى السياسيه
سودانيه ونحن نقول من الان ان الحوار مع
مع الاخرين مفتوح وايدينا وقلوبنا وعقولنا
مفتوحه للحوار مع الاخر نحن ومن هم يكونون
حكومه الوفاق الوطني طيب اشكرك جزيلا
الامين عبد الرازق الامين السياسي لحزب
المؤتمر الشعبي واشكر السيده مريم الصادق
المهدي نائبه رئيس حزب الامه القومي من
السودان لم يعد ملف التاثير الروسي على
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه لم يعد
مجرد جدل اعلامي وسياسي فقد تحول الى
استقاله وقرار اقاله لمسؤولين بارزين هذا
عدا عما قد تحمله التحقيقات من مفاجات غاد
عويس والمحطه الاخيره من حصاد اليوم